[Música]
yo soy música toco un instrumento muy
raro que se llama la flauta traversa
barroca y la flauta que se utilizaba en
la época de baja de vivaldi
hace un poquito más de 20 años pusimos
por primera vez en el teatro colon una
ópera barroca tocada con instrumentos
históricos la ópera se llamaba las
indias galantes de un compositor francés
del siglo 18 y éramos músicos de todas
partes era una fiesta
mientras
estábamos ensayando
yo
recibí un mail muy extraño
un mail de mi hijo que vivía en europa
que decía
me voy a internar en un manicomio para
escribir una gran obra de arte
yo en ese momento no sabía si era un
delirio o si estábamos hablando de arte
y ante la duda consulte con un
profesional que me dijo esto puede ser
grave hay que ir a buscarlo
entonces en medio del ensayo me levanté
le conté lo que me pasaba al director
que me dio un abrazo me dio un beso en
la frente y me dijo anda anda a buscar a
tu hijo
un compañero oboísta que vivía en
holanda me dio la llave de su
departamento y ahí empezó a formarse una
red increíble de amigos de amigos de
amigos
para tratar de averiguar a dónde estaba
mi hijo porque lo único que sabíamos era
que estaba en holanda
e
a los tres o cuatro días yo estaba
volando con mi hermana y cuando llegamos
a ámsterdam ya sabíamos en qué ciudad y
en qué sanatorio estaba recuerden en
aquella época no usábamos whatsapp
tampoco existían los móviles así que fue
todo una proeza
lo encontramos en un estado terrible
estaba totalmente fuera de sí no sabía
ni quién era estaba eufórico totalmente
pasado de rosca con un brote psicótico
producido por una ingesta increíble de
drogas
en el hospital nos permitieron salir con
él durante el día
para tratar de convencerlo de volver a
la argentina cosa que él no quería saber
ni a palos y bueno entonces durante 15
días mi hermana y yo vivimos una
película atrás de mi hijo y sus amigos
para tratar de convencerlo de volver
cosa que logramos
y bueno ahí empezó nuestra vida en la
montaña rusa
eso es estar siempre al borde de la
cornisa es dar vueltas para un lado dar
vueltas para el otro nunca sabes para
qué lado a veces subir despacito
despacito despacito despacito y caes
muchas veces yo sentí que caí en el
mismísimo infierno
por suerte siempre logré salir
las primeras emociones que yo sentí en
esa época fueron al principio negación
no podía creer que esto estaba pasando
después una confusión de tristeza enojo
de todo un poco
y durante mucho tiempo lo que más sentí
era vergüenza vergüenza y culpa
porque de esto no se habla
yo tengo 63 años y recién hace 3 que
puedo hablar públicamente de esto y
cuando digo de esto estoy diciendo que
tengo un hijo que tiene una enfermedad
que se llama esquizofrenia asociada a un
consumo muy problemático de sustancias
ninguna de estas enfermedades seguras
son para siempre pero si se pueden
mantener
y con un equipo terapéutico adecuado que
en el caso de mi hijo es increíble más
la contención de parte de la familia la
medicación de última generación y
fundamentalmente su inmenso esfuerzo
personal y le está logrando hacer una
vida muy digna y bonita
yo sé muy bien
que posiblemente si mi hijo hubiese
nacido
en una zona vulnerabilidad a de la
ciudad en una de esas hoy no estaría
vivo estaría en la cárcel
en el 2020 a todas y todos nos pasó esto
de la pandemia
con todo lo que la pandemia trajo no mi
hijo habitualmente vive en una
residencia
compartida o casa de medio camino que es
un dispositivo que existe a partir de la
nueva ley de salud mental
entonces vino a mi casa por unos días
porque esas casas fueron cerradas
esos unos días se convirtieron en un año
y medio si ahí me hubiese dicho que mi
hijo iba a venir a casa por un año y
medio le juro que yo me hubiera escapado
a cualquier lado me hubiera trepado al
himalaya hubiese hecho cualquier cosa
con tal de no tener que pasar por esa
experiencia
sin embargo hoy puedo decir que fue una
bendición fue una inmensa posibilidad
una inmensa posibilidad de volver a
reconstruir un vínculo afectivo de madre
e hijo que luego de tantos años de
enfermedad estaba por lo menos dañado
fue una posibilidad de convivir de
compartir de aprender un montón de cosas
juntos
y no solo fue una posibilidad para mi
hijo y para mí sino también para el hijo
de mi hijo que es mi nietito de 6 años
que pudo venir a casa semana de por
medio y compartir con nosotros compartir
fundamentalmente con su papá que es un
hermoso cuidador
pero bueno
yo no me di cuenta pero todo esto tuvo
una consecuencia en mi salud
yo estuve 500 días de guardia
y necesite ayuda médica
yo también otra vez
las personas las cuidadoras de personas
y digo las porque en general somos
mujeres
también necesitamos ser cuidadas
el prototipo de una persona que cuida a
otra persona con enfermedad mental es
una mujer de 64 años que hace más de 20
cuida en un promedio de 25 horas
semanales a su ser querido
dentro de poco me convierto en el
prototipo me siento el prototipo hoy
en los aviones
las azafatas dicen que en caso de que
ocurra algo va a caer adelante nuestro
una mascarilla y que si uno viaja con un
menor primero tiene que ponerse la
mascarilla luego se la pone al menor y
va a estar todo bárbaro un día poniendo
especial de atención a eso pensé que hoy
está que horrible como lo voy a salvar
yo primero y después ocuparme de otro y
muy de pasada se lo comenté a mi
psicóloga que me dijo pero de eso se
trata si no te cuidamos primero cómo va
a cuidar a otros
y esa metáfora me quedo para siempre
y me preguntó las mujeres somos las
únicas capacitadas para cuidar para
contener para hacer tiernas empáticas
para poner límites para hacer todo lo
necesario
para poder cuidar a otro quien dijo eso
acaso tiene un gen especial para eso las
mujeres que tenemos una profesión y
tenemos un hijo con estas
características
tenemos derecho a ejercer nuestra
profesión
por suerte hoy del tema de cuidados se
habla muchísimo más y las nuevas
generaciones
están logrando compartir de manera más
equitativa
el tema de cuidados y no sólo eso sino
también todo lo que tiene que ver con
vivir en una casa y eso la verdad que me
alegra pero todavía falta falta un
montón
hoy hoy yo vivo la música desde otro
lugar hago una actividad que a mí me
permitió vivir de un modo mucho más
saludable y que se llama bio danza en la
que la música ocupa un rol central
biodanza es un sistema de integración
afectiva en el que se trabaja siempre de
manera grupal en el que se cultiva la
empatía en el que buscamos en nuestras
emociones para poder vivirlas de modo
saludable
y cuando pienso en emociones también se
me pasa por la cabeza es decir que en
este en esta cultura que hemos ido
construyendo con divisiones de roles tan
insólitas por ahí quizás también hay
varones que están muy solos
o que están tristes
o que tienen miedo o incluso
necesidad de llorar y no se animan
porque en la cultura está mal visto en
esta sociedad
y hay que pensar en eso
y yo luego de tantos años lo que he
aprendido es primero que hay que hablar
porque lo que no se nombra no existe
segundo el autocuidado sin culpa para
poder cuidar a otros y tercero que la
salida es siempre grupal es siempre
colectiva es siempre cooperativa es
siempre en red es así como esa red
maravillosa que se armó y que me cuido
tanto hace más de 20 años
ojalá en la sociedad
hagamos redes cada día mas entramadas
más empáticas más inclusivas
porque todas y todos
merecemos vivir vidas más vivibles
[Música]